a University of Southern California
student is speaking out about the
recruiting tactics of the alleged
mastermind behind the college admissions
scandal Rick singers his name he pleaded
guilty and led prosecutors to more than
30 parents those indicted include
actresses Felicity Huffman and Lori
Lachlan the student we spoke with is
asked to remain anonymous
she says that Rick singer approached her
mother with an offer that seemed too
good to be true and we know how this
ends it was Carter Evans is at USC with
more on this joy Carter good morning
good morning the USC student basically
says that singer solicited her mother as
a client after a referral from a friend
now she thought his services were
totally legitimate at the time until he
resurfaced as the face of this
multi-million dollar scandal knowing
everything I know now I just think thank
God because that could have been me in
the midst of her college application
process this 21 year old says her mother
got a call from Rick singer he asked her
what my grades were he asked her what my
ect score was she told him and he said
oh those aren't getting her into Ivy
League's she says singer told her mom he
knew how to guarantee admission into
Stanford he goes oh you know is she
athletically involved in any way is she
a star athlete and my mom says this girl
can't play anything she's terrible at
athletics and he kind of just said I
won't it won't be a problem
she didn't think it was anything weird
she just thought wow this guy must be so
good at his job that it doesn't matter
that my daughter can't shoot a
basketball she ultimately turned down
the offer but the pitch apparently
worked for others
Davina Isaacson seen here leaving court
Monday was named in the federal
indictment along with her husband it
says their oldest daughter got into UCLA
after submitting fake soccer credentials
the university's website lists Lauren
Isaacson is a midfielder on the 2017
team but she was not pictured in the
team photo the site also says she was
team captain at the Woodside Soccer Club
from 2012 to 2016 but a club official
tells CBS this morning they have no
record of her ever being there
we were hoping to learn more about what
motivated Rik singer by speaking with
his lawyer dawn Heller
but minutes before our scheduled
interview Wednesday Heller told us an
assistant US attorney called and
discouraged him from talking to the
media reminding him that his client was
cooperating with the prosecution in a
statement the Department of Justice told
us mr. Heller needs to decide what is in
his and his clients best interest the
government will not try this case in the
media I look back now and I think of him
as just this slimy salesman who probably
pitched the same thing to every naive
parent and kid the USC student says she
can see how a scheme like this can be
fueled by the intense pressures of
getting into college it just kind of
goes to show how easily people can be
swindled into things and how our culture
values getting into prestigious
universities so highly that people are
willing to do things like this now when
it comes to the most high-profile people
involved in this case Full House actress
Lori Loughlin and her husband are due in
a Boston courtroom next week Felicity
Huffman --zz court date has been
postponed she's due back in court next
month both are out on bail a lot of
interest in this story thank you very
much Carter